hi i'm mia sue and today i'm with
buzzfeed and i'm talking about
my first times
first memory onset of dance moms i think
my first memory i was like nine years
old so it's kind of hard to remember
my first like memory memory though would
probably be like
auditioning for the show in the car on
the way back home
my mom told me she was like nia you did
this but just so you know
you're not gonna get it we're just too
boring look where we are now
first time meeting michelle obama oh
my gosh i shed a tear like i was in
shock after i
i needed several like breaths after
because i was
i was so excited i was meeting michelle
obama but then i also like met
john legend and like just oh my gosh so
many just
amazing celebrities and people that i
look look up to
so yeah just meeting michelle obama was
amazing
first time you realize you're famous i
still don't really think i'm famous but
like the first time i was like
recognized
in public
oh we were at a dance competition and
it was like the first time someone asked
for a picture with us we were all just
so excited like oh my gosh people want
pictures with us and i still get excited
when
when people like want pictures first
experience filming
dance with nia oh my gosh my first
experience filming dance with mia
after the first day i was just filled
with so much love
honestly like my heart was so full the
first dancer we had her name was lark
and she was just amazing and like such a
great dancer but also
we bonded really well and we talked
about even like going to a dance class
after two so you know i i created a lot
of friends on that show
and just filming it was just a dream
come true
first celebrity crush
cody simpson was my first celebrity
crush along with justin bieber those
were my two favorites and i still
love them oh first impression of your
podcast co-host and bestie tila done
oh my gosh wait so the first time i met
tila was at like my first
gifting suite in la and i was probably
like 11 years old
she was just so sweet to me we were both
so young oh my goodness it was so long
ago and whenever like i kind of moved
out here for
dance moms uh she would hang out with me
or like i was getting into youtube so
she would make youtube videos with me
it was so sweet like he was a sweetheart
first dance moms co-star you text to
hang out with
right now literally all of them i love
each and every one of them
maybe paige because it's been like a
really long time but i also haven't seen
maddie in a hot minute either
i'll get lunch with kenzie sometimes not
like i'll go over to chloe's apartment
we'll hang out sometimes like i'm
i'm so close with all the girls and
they're amazing and i miss them all i
miss them all first ridiculous
untrue rumor you heard about yourself um
one of like the rumors i heard about
myself which is just
not true people were posting this when i
was on dance moves they were like
mia was see a second choice for
chandelier i'm like people know
i wasn't naughty i was not the second
choice
like oh my gosh i was like where are
people getting this information from
another one currently would be that i
have a boyfriend
guys i haven't had a boyfriend in a
really long time i
like i have no plans on getting one i
don't have a boyfriend and a story
and people can stop wondering if i do or
not not in a relationship
first time you realized you wanted to be
a performer
[Music]
i don't know i feel like i was just born
a performer honestly
like growing up in the dance world like
i always knew that i was
going to be a performer in some capacity
even from when i was little like i
always wanted to be on broadway
since i was itty bitty first time you
are starstruck
oh my gosh i still get starstruck so
first time i went to the teen choice
awards i was probably like 11 years old
justin bieber was walking in the carpet
and we all wanted a picture with justin
bieber so we have
so he like motioned us over to take a
picture with him and we were so excited
we like literally started crying
and he we literally have a picture with
justin bieber on the red carpet at the
teen choice awards and then also
i met gabby douglas the year after and
she was like my
number one role model person that i
looked up to and i still do she's
amazing
and i was at the teen choice awards and
my mom was like me i have someone i want
you to meet
and she was like turn around and i
turned around and it's literally gabby
douglas and i start bawling my eyes out
and i was like
like the picture that i have with her my
eyes are like
i was an ugly cry but a very happy and
just like star struck cry as well
first quarantined binge watch well it
was either outer banks
or on my black i think may have been on
my block though either way
both of them are amazing first red
carpet experience
i think that was the teen choice awards
as well like whenever i met justin
bieber we were so excited i i had this
really long pink
dress on i don't know why i thought that
was so amazing i
like it was not cute i mean it was cute
because it was little but like i was
like why girl why did you choose a dress
i was 11 years old this was like the
coolest thing
i had ever done and meeting so many
amazing celebrities and people that i
looked up to
it was just so cool and i was just so
excited i was so tiny
and finally the first piece of advice
you'd give to your younger self oh my
gosh everything happens for a reason
i live by that statement i truly do
i also think that knowing your worth is
another one that i would tell my younger
self my mom used to tell me that one
when i was younger same with star in
your own life so
i live by a lot of mottos but all of
those things i would tell
my younger self and be confident because
you have nothing not to be confident
with
so that would be it thank you so much
for having me buzzfeed
make sure you check out my new show
dance with mia
you